[音楽]
着物を繰り返す
着物日本のファッションシステムの
背景
西洋のファッション理論家は、
ファッション
はヨーロッパで出現し、そこから広まったと言っています。
これは、
ヨーロッパには
ファッションアイテムを作る技術が適切であると考えられていた
ためです。 ファッションシステムが発展するための経済的政治的および
社会的条件
東アジアまたはアフリカ諸国がファッションシステムを持つことができるとは考えられていなかった
西洋の理論家はまた、
ファッションは形の変化であり、
他の種類の変化はない
ので、着物は ファッション
衣服着物は千年もの間大きく形を変えていませんでしたが
、伝統的な衣服としての幾何学的な仕立てのないデザインのために体を無視する
と考えられていました。新しいものではなく過去を大切にすると考えられてい
たため、ファッション理論家
は着物を ファッション
ガーメントの
高貴なハイアンスタイルしかし
、私の研究では、
日本にはファッションシステムがあったことがわかりました em少なくとも中世以来、
私
は古いものよりも新しいものに興味があり、
グループのサトリアルな行動があったことを示すリーダーとフォロワーがいることに気づき
ました。私は個人的なスタイルが非常に
重要であり、その形が
多くの場合
、ヘイエン時代にファッションの犠牲者を生み出す機能よりも重要で
あり、花を表すローブの色の組み合わせは
72シーズン中に変更され、スタイリッシュな
女性
は自然界や他の人々よりも先を行くことが期待され
ていました
[ 音楽]
何層ものガウンを着た女性は
、顔を見せたり外を動き回ったりすることができず
、家の中の花のように根付いていました。
今日まで
洋服
と和装の両方で、今では
20キロを着ている女性はテロと呼ばれています 足より
少なくとも1
メートル長い布や
下着は、江戸時代までにヨーロッパの裁判所の対応者と同じくらい多くのファッションの犠牲者でした。また、
衣料品メーカーや流通業者の
スタイルブックやスタイルを備えた本格的な経済システムもありました。 アイコン
と最新の服に熱心な市場
私は着物の5つの魅力的な側面を紹介したいと思い
ます最初に柔軟性2番目
に根付いている3番目に接続性
4番目に日本を表現する能力
そして5番目に
品質と革新の両方に関心がある
最初の着物の柔軟性
着物
が幾何学的で仕立てられた形のために体を無視し
たという西洋のファッション理論家の考えは
、フィッティングがカットプロセスではなくドレッシングプロセスで行われることを完全に誤解していました。
これ
は、体を9または10のサイズに強制する必要がないことを意味します
または12またはll
それはどんなサイズまたは形または体で
も優雅に包むことができることを意味します 同じ
着物が体にフィットするように着物を着
たら着物は仕上がりません
obや
様々なアクセサリー
を追加すると、スタイリング
が行われるスタイリングが起こります着物はベース
キャンバスです
これ
たった1つの着物でいくつものルックスを作ることができるということです。
また、着物は世代を超えて簡単に渡ることができ、
長持ちするということは、
次の
着物の根性をより持続可能にすることです。
パンツとTシャツがどこに来たのかわかりません。
最悪の状況で搾取された労働者によって作られ
、裕福な国で消費されるために出荷される
ことが多い
ため、2015年の毎日のメールによると、
どこからともなく
すぐにゴミに着物になりますが、平均して7回着ています。
誰が私の着物を作ったのかを知ることはできますが、着物
を着ている人と着物を作る職人との間にはしばしば関係が
ありますが、彼らが尊敬する職人からの着物によって
、彼らはそれを使って着物を作ります y
彼らの物語の一部
これらの職人は順番にそれらの
顧客
を大切にし、彼らのニーズを満たすために最善を尽くします
私はまた私の着物がどこから来たのかを知ることができます
日本の地理のために
特定の繊維は異なる場所から来ています
地理的要因
特定の場所で特定の染色および製織技術
が開発され
ました。たとえば、
東京、京都、
金沢は絞りの使用と
染色技術の
アリマット
で有名で、長野は紬織りで有名です。
私の着物は日本にルーツがあり、私は
世話をします。 祖母
や母が
着ていた服を着たら、次の着物のつながりを捨てないで
ください。最初は少し奇妙に見えますが、
私には合わないかもしれません。
確かに、
古風で時代遅れに
見えます。
ちょっと変ですが
、
おばあちゃんやお母さん
が着ていた着物を着るのは簡単でしょう。 私の
コレクション
といくつかのアクセサリーから
、21世紀に再起動さ
れます。このようにして、着物は祖母
と母と娘をつなぎます。
これ
は、友人の間
や、オンラインとハイストリートの両方で中古の着物店を介して受け継がれるためです。
着物を着ると人は優しく、
着物を着ている人はお互いに親しみを感じ、
知らない人同士でもコミュニケーションが生まれることが多い
次の着物は日本
を表現する日本の着物は日本の美
を体現する日本のアイデンティティの表現です
毎世代のニーズに合わせて変化した美しさの概念
に加えて、シルクは産業革命における日本の歴史の重要な部分であり
、
日本一の
輸出製品であり、
日本が近代化するために必要なすべての新素材にお金を払っていました
テキスタイルの生産は、常に
日本の文化経済史の重要な部分でした。
着物を
着ているこの日本の物語の一部である
着物は、魔法のように
ファッションと伝統の両方
であり、日本の歴史の国民服であるだけでなく
、ファッショナブルなアイデンティティを表現するための手段でもあり
ます。 これらの拠点はとてもよくできています
最後に私
はすべての世代の着物の品質と革新への取り組みについて話したいと思います着物職人
は時代に関連する主題
と新しいテキスタイルの両方で新しくて現代的な製品を作るために努力してきました 江戸時代
にシボリや刺繡が
大衆に禁じられたときの革新
綿が高価な輸入
品であったときに使用染色技術が開発された日本の変態地域で国内の綿産業が始まり
、 江戸時代の終わり
最近、新しい色と染料が
デジタル印刷と機械刺繡に追加されまし
た精神o  f革新
は21世紀まで続き
、織工や染色機の側で多くの実験が行われてい
ます。織る革
糸
下着用の洗える絹はすべて
最近開発されまし
た。江戸時代の時代に合わせてデザインが常に変更され
ました。 タイのショー期間は
、ハリウッドと戦争の両方で
着物のデザインに登場しました。
最近、カード、猫、
ヘビ、星、鉄のシート
、ディズニーのキャラクターでさえ
着物のスタイリストに登場し、
新しい雑誌は
新しいアイテムを紹介し、提案し続けています。
着物をスタイリングする新しい革新的な方法衣服の品質
と顧客の満足度は、安価で劣った商品
の長蛇の列の生産よりも常に重要です。
日本のテキスタイルは世界クラスの
品質で
あり、細部へのこだわりと美学を体現し
ています。 日本のすべての芸術に見られる
[音楽]
私の結論は、それは時間
fであるということです または着物のリビート日本
の素晴らしい織物の遺産を認識する時が来
ましたスタイルと誇りを持ってあなたの文化を身につける
時が来
ましたそしてあなた自身の着物のファッションであなた自身を表現する時が来ました